vous avez une compile de l'attitude de
mickaël lumière donc le comédien qui a
joué grégory lemarchal regarde comment
tu vas ça va ça c'est un petit ça va ça
qu'est ce qu'il ya si je me demandais ce
que est ce que vous pensez que si
j'étais pas mal à dire la même chose
arrête de verser merde
disque ou encore 10 ou rien en face te
plaît tu sais très bien qu'il raconte
que je suis là parce que j'ai la muco
que c'est truqué que tu es ici parce que
tu chantes comme personne ta voix est
unique
quand un petit con la ressemblance c'est
quand même hannah est incroyable alors
est-ce que vous avez aimé ou pas le
documentaire à lucie bernardoni qui est
avec nous qui était chanteuse et
ancienne camarade de grégory fêtions
finale d'ailleurs antoine contre grégory
voilà lors de la star ac 4 vous est-ce
que vous avez retrouvé ce que vous aviez
vécu dans l'ensemble nos rangs moi ce
que j'ai vécu avec lui dans toutes les
scènes du château pas vraiment ah oui
après c'est vrai que c'est un 92 minutes
il faut qu'on dansait sur le message
passe la seule certitude qu'on a c'est
que le message est passé en tout cas
pour ben pour la muco et pour les gens
qui ne connaissaient pas forcément
maintenant oui à des inexactitudes ya
des arts vous avez choisi la pire baisse
était d'abord merci
et oui il ya des inexactitudes
en fait c'est vrai que lors des scènes
de la star ac dans le château il a l'air
assez solitaire il est représenté comme
étant assez solitaire et en fait c'était
pas du tout ça c'est à dire qu'on était
un groupe on était en était unie pas
d'ailleurs on l'est encore aujourd'hui
mais ça vient de quelque part en fait ça
vient de là il était parfaitement
intégrée et je dirais même dans les
meneurs quoi et c'est vrai que c'est il
est vrai qu'on l'a vu il était plus fou
que ce qu'on croyait
ah oui les gorilles regarder pendant
tout le documentaire d'après on voit
grégory était tout sauf introverti
regarder ses seins comme on dit chez moi
c'est un cheat and ça veut dire que
c'est un petit diable
depuis sa disparition souvent on dit de
lui c'est le petit enjeu machin mais en
fait qu'est-ce qui se marrait de dire je
suis un petit ange
parce que c'est il était très très très
très drôle quoi
lalala lalala lalala lalala lalala
[Musique]
cinéma fiat et la balle tu viens il vous
faut alors vous ne rêvez ou pas valérie
benaïm non non et pourtant je suis la
première à dire qu'il fallait faire ce
biopic parce que les parents le
souhaitait et donc il n'y a plus de ya
pas de discussion quand les parents
souhaitent
point barre mais j'ai été déçu par
l'objet télévisuelle si j'étais déçu par
le téléfilm lui-même admis a pas mises à
part du crest et mickaël lumière que
j'ai trouvé exceptionnel
j'ai trouvé que ça jouait pas très bien
d'accord que la mise en scène n'était
pas extraordinaire la réalisation non
plus et qu'on survole est effectivement
temps en mettant en lumière des choses
que peut-être lui n'aurait pas souhaité
qu'on met pour le coup tout à fait en
lumière et on oublie en d'autres
d'autres choses alors vous allez me dire
effectivement 92 minutes il faut aller
très vite
mais les choix qui ont été faits j'ai
pas aimé les chevaux curité alors on a
pu voir notamment dans le biopic guerre
une scène où grégory abandonne un cours
de danse alors que sont tous ses anciens
camarades il ne baissait jamais les bras
et ça ça en a énervé certain regard des
5 6 7 1 lucie talents vers arles mt à
contretemps greg à te cacher derrière
toi même stoppé la danse se taire je
veux 0 excuses dans mon cours parce que
demain il ya des éliminations bon savez
quoi prenez cinq minutes et renvoyer
l'entrepôt
ça je
que ça
vous
[Musique]
ici est ce que c'est vrai normalement il
a bandé il a abandonné jamais donc ça ça
faisait un peu il n'ya pas énervé mais
bon un petit peu cher que ça m'a fait
face à ma pas ça m'a peiné déjà de voir
une scène comme ça parce que juste
michael lumière il est parfait je me
permets de le dire exceptionnel vraiment
il n'ya rien à dire là-dessus on veut
nous voir la voix je me permettais juste
mais oui il était il faisait les cours
avec nous et ils partaient pas comme ça
alors peut-être ça lui est arrivé une
fois peut-être je dis bien peut-être moi
je les ai pas vus en tout cas mais ça ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas arrivé alors
encore une fois voilà il faut
certainement condensé etc
mais moi ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que il se plaignait pas mais là il
abandonne pas c'est le prof qui dit on
fait une pause deux minutes et dix je
vais pisser je reviens ouais mais ont
donné leur est alors des montagnes mais
toi moi j'ai adoré j'ai adoré j'ai dorée
du début jusqu'à la fin j'ai regardé le
reportage derrière où les parents ont
dit qu il les appelait à chaque fois
pour demander si c'était bon si c'était
bien ou pas ce qu'on est en train de
faire les parents ont dit oui c'est très
bien ce que vous invite à bien sûr qu'il
ya un côté fiction
moi j'aime et j'ai même un moment donné
quand il annonce que sa mère à 12h tu es
pris pour graines de stars j'ai même eu
un truc qui est montée j'ai tu vas pas
te mettre à pleurer devant un biopic
quand même moi j'ai adoré
et voilà je toujours comprends pas
pourquoi les gens autour commence à dire
julie d'hier et je redis aujourd'hui je
comprends pas pourquoi ya une polémique
autour de ces n'y a aucune polémique là
on parle de l'eau jean paul objet
télévisuel
j'avais envie d'y aller les magnifiques
savoir quand on dit il amer mais on peut
ne pas dévoiler le droit de dire ce qu
avait bien sûr alors moi l'un des
moments les plus touchants du biopic
c'est lorsque la maman de grégory joué
par odile villemin après que son fils
grégory est touché par la mucoviscidose
à la prends ça c'est un moment très
touchant c'est un grand moment du
téléfilm avez vous déjà entendu parler
de la mucoviscidose est ce que c'est
c'est une maladie génétique qui obstrue
les voies respiratoires empêcher de
respirer correctement et atteint le
système digestif
ah non pas du tout ma faim greg fait des
grosses bronchiolite c'est ce qu'on a
toujours dit mais à part ça il est en
pleine santé
ces examens et notamment son test des
sueurs indique taux de chlore très élevé
c'est symptomatique mal mais comme ici
pour cette maladie il n'y a pas très tôt
en tout cas pas pour guérir alors voilà
donc ça c'était un moment très fort
jean-pierre n'ai pas aimé oui j'ai pas
aimé j'espère que je vais pas mal me
faire comprendre
mais voilà j'ai pas aimé parce que je
trouvais que la ville malheureusement de
grégory lemarchal a été tragiquement
trop courte pour cent face un objet
télévisuel suffisamment dense pour qu'on
en fasse une histoire qui tienne en
haleine pendant deux heures ils avaient
été bourré de talent il a une mort
tragique et c'est un exemple de courage
pour plein de personnes mais
malheureusement sa vie je savais avant
de voir quand j'ai vu le téléfilm j'ai
rien appris et l'a fait la star ac
il avait fait un peu de sport avant il
souffrait d' abus commis ces doses mais
sa feinte savait pas ce téléfilm de deux
heures on aurait préféré un documentaire
sur lui sur la microvision mais le
téléfilm en lui-même c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas assez riches
si je suis désolé ce juge j'ai presque
honte de dire ça mais ça méritait pas un
téléfilm
cette mesure est mérité un document du
ral d'envoyer ça méritait un document
est un document t tiens un appel aux
dons planète énorme phénomène tu dis
bien sûr mais moi j'ai suivi ce
documentaire jeter en âge de le suivre
j'ai rien appris non je l'adorais gré
mais si j'étais content de ça j'étais
content de sa victoire
j'étais triste de son décès évidemment
mais j'ai rien appris hier soir les
émotions à prendre lors si ça a aidé ou
dont tant mieux alors ya des moments où
on va on va revenir sur les propos de
jean-michel dans un instant il ya des
moments qui a fait le plus réagir c'est
quand grégory découvre sa voix
exceptionnelle
il est dans sa chambre en train de
chanter son père par arnaud ducret une
découvre son talent cas
[Musique]
sans ça vaut rien tu as eu la force
d'aimer nous aurons d'un moment le monde
entier
enfin longtemps puisse faire ça c'est
quoi chanter comme ça quoi
alors bernard montiel et jean michel
vous dites que vous allez oui
non moi je pas d'accord avec lui
évidemment moi j'ai trouvé le film
tellement émouvant que j'ai pas voulu
voir la fin j'ai pas vu la fin du film
puisque on la connaît la fin
malheureusement je crois qu'il est
important il ya un pan de l'histoire qui
était importante c'est de voir le
quotidien d'un malade c'est extrêmement
important et langue bien montrer là ils
sont pas passés à côté
que ce soit le masque à oxygène les
aérosols la kiné respiratoire
ça c'est important pour tous les malades
et pour toutes les familles qui vivent
ce drame parce que c'est un drame pour
ça moi j'ai trouvé très bien réalisé moi
j'ai trouvé très émouvant
je reconnais j'ai pas vu la fin parce
que voilà c'est tout très triste je vais
pas envie hier soir d'être triste alors
justement parlant de la fin c'est un
moment très touchant du film y en a eu
plein mais malheureusement c'est quand
grégory ne peut plus lutter et qui va
succomber à sa maladie après s'être
battue pendant tant d'années
regardez il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
dit qu'ils avaient sapé avant la fin
prêt il pouvait pas voir ça regardez
chaque année en france 800 personnes
meurent en attente d'organes qui
n'arrivant jamais
comme grégory alors même si depuis 2010
est la loi fait de nous tous des
donneurs présumés personne ne peut
souhaiter qu'une greffe arrive le plus
vite possible car ce serait souhaité que
sur cette terre quelqu'un possédant des
poumons compatible moeurs
et pourtant et pourtant la mort sert
parfois autre chose que faire pleurer
les vivants
je ne sais pas quand je ne sais pas
comment
et un jour nous trouverons un remède et
nous croyons que des associations comme
la nôtre
et par an nous serait vrai elle
alors voilà c'est un des gros du film
géraldine c'est vrai que dire qu'on n'a
pas aimé quand on voit ça effectivement
ça paraît irrecevable parce que ce qui
compte effectivement problème c'est vrai
que moi un garçon qu'on adorait tous
moi je suis papa hier il a été
exceptionnel absolument roule l objet
télévisuel moi j'ai été extrait
excessivement déçu j'ai trouvé c'était
raté de bout en bout
hormis l'interprétation des acteurs j'ai
trouvé qu'ils avaient aucune espèce
d'émotion moi mon baromètre c'est que
les biens avec trois ados il a trois
ados connaissait pas grégory lemarchal
parce que nous tous ici on l'a connu on
l'a aimé on l'admiré on a été peiné et
moi j'ai vu avec des ados qui ne
connaissaient pas mais ils ont
complètement décrochés n'ont pas été
touchés ils ont pas été embarqués et
pourtant ils ont vu plein de
documentaire plein de biopic
ils ont aimé le documentaire après ils
ont pas aimé la fiction parce que je
trouvais que c'était une construction un
peu alambiqué c'était pas bien filmé
s'était pas réalisé de fin j'ai trouvé
que c'était complètement ratée et je
trouve que c'est dommage mais tant mieux
si ça a cartonné et tant mieux s'il ya
plein de dettes alors on va vous a fait
un petit comparatif entre les ce qui
s'est passé dans le biopic et les
archives les vraies images et cette
séquence qu'on va ou sur laquelle on va
revenir ses téléspectateurs selon les
téléspectateurs la plus réussie du
biopic on voit la prestation qui a sans
doute fait de grégory lemarchal une
superstar c'est son interprétation de
sos d'un terrien en détresse
regardez la séquence du clos puis
qu'hier comparé à la séquence
[Musique]
d'un terrien en détresse j
pieds sur terre
m
cheval domaine
[Musique]
le marché va se passer bientôt
c'est super bien faire c'est juste qu'il
y en a un qui descend les marches et un
qui descendent par les marchés est ce
que ça change beaucoup
moi j'ai pas regardé parce que comme
j'ai dis moi ça me rend triste et je
n'aime pas ça mais c'est vrai que le
talent du comédien quand tu auras des
deux camps c'est fort super bien croire
c'est alors on a découvert hier soir
aussi que les scénaristes du biopic ont
rejoué à ses comptes ou de grégory
lemarchal découvre sa performance et
qu'ils font littéralement en larmes
ça aussi c'était une séquence forte
regarder la complète comparatif total
enfants
[Musique]
et pas comme tout le monde grégory
comprend comme les autres je me suis
beaucoup a retenu parce que j'ai fait et
cracker maman j'ai pensé que j'allais
craquer en fait
c'est pas comme s'il n'y avait pas les
frères gérard louvin c'est vrai c'est
pas le vrai gérard louvin c'est vrai
c'est rageant c'est toujours aussi que
ça qui est différent je vois pas le sait
pour moi c'est la même chose
non j'ai pas aimé marche bien évidemment
que du que de l'oeuvre et surtout j'ai
pas aimé puisqu'ils étaient les scènes
sur la sur la star ac parce
qu'effectivement quand on a vu les ce
qu'ils ont reconstitué là franchement on
dirait une kermesse de fin d'année ya
personne c'est tout vide on est on est
pas près par l'émotion et je trouve que
le début est intéressant que toute la
phase on découvre ça valide sa wii et
après tout la carrière il en veut enfin
quand quand ça décolle pour moi j'aimais
c'était au rabais est vraiment pas steve
wallace était mal fait et ça me stresse
à très décevant voile alors ils ont fait
aussi la scène où on découvre l'uci qui
la finale face à vous c'était le moment
le plus réaliste selon certains regardez
là le comparatif entre la réalité et la
fiction
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la star academy est reporté
google
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
régalez vous
les gangs de données qui se tient ce
soir
k
cyril le seul fait qu'on voit là c'est
pas le moment d'élire voilà il est super
bon animateur au abbas mohtaj a parlé on
voit bien regarder la différence entre
la fête à l'époque la réalité est là il
ya personne son plateau ils ont même pas
mis un musicien franchement ils sont
payés sont pas foulés voilà je trouve ça
très long pour ça après le reste
évidemment on va pas revenir dessus
c'est très bien de l'avoir fait et si ça
peut aider
évidemment tout va bien mais pour le
travail que vous êtes très
professionnels de la télé comme
assesseur al-din vous avez trop chercher
à regarder vraiment les trucs les envers
il ya combien 400 cotillons là et là il
y en avait que deux sens je vois juste
que l'ue si elle le prend dans les bras
et dans le temps là dans la fiction et
ils se prennent aussi dans les bras je
ne cherche pas de savoir si la tremblère
ça c'est vrai que ça ça tient aussi la
télé je perds mais je suis d'abord je
pense que vous êtes internat les deux
alors il ya ça m'a manqué à leur venue
sur les coulisses de ce biopic
elle a dit une chose qui est interpellé
elle n'était pas vraiment très ouverte à
l'idée de faire un biopic regarder les
années faisant j'avais toujours ce souci
avec l'image de voir grégory incarner à
l'écran et après pierre leslie et
d'autres personnes m'ont fait on trouve
voix entrevoir une possibilité de faire
passer un message
je me souviens un jour j'ai dit ok tu
dis ok ah ben je sais c'était le ok mais
avec le concours de boule au ventre a
jeté mon dieu
[Applaudissements]
là quand on a vu ça on était bouleversée
mais avant moi je n'étais pas le
bouleverser du tout c'était vraiment le
look de globo pic n'est pas content et
je passe le travail qu'on aime avoir
l'avis des téléspectateurs génial moi
c'est ça on avait tellement d'attentes
il y avait trop d'attentes peut-être une
déception alors on a vu aussi les
beaucoup les parents dans le
documentaire écrit qu'on aime énormément
et son papa notamment un nombre at et
tout n'est pas fidèle à la réalité est
la part de fiction elle rentre s'il dans
l'histoire mais elle ne le dénature pas
les valeurs qu'on a dans la famille les
valeurs de grégory donc ça on a on a
bien veillé à sare en fait même si on
n'est pas les producteurs du téléfilm et
les choses où ils nous ont fait
confiance en vous c'est pas comme ça
mais on comprend que dans la fiction il
ya besoin de ça donc ça ça a été une
paire enrichissant après le jour on l'a
fait rencontrer le comédien qui va
interpréter grégory moi j'avais le
trouillomètre à zéro le jour de cette
rencontre là je me dis mais comment
est-ce qu'ils peuvent avoir envie de le
rencontrer quoi c'est hyper dur
il ya des gens qui ravit surtout des
reprises du nom de ce que dit géraldine
d'accord avec moi mais moi j'ai le droit
aussi de dire que c'est vous avez vous
avez vous avez vous avez tous les droits
ici un an défend la cause on bien soin
de ne pas aimer le téléphone alors
malgré toutes les critiques pierre
lemarchal est revenu sur tout ça pour
délivrer un beau message hier soir chez
nous donc il a aimé la fiction pierre
lemarchal or il ya beaucoup de tweets au
cours de la soirée
et c'est vrai le truc qui a fait le plus
parler ses clients les internautes ont
remarqué qu'il y avait pas mal aussi
d'incohérences
c'est à dire que les scénaristes ont
obligé de changer les décors du qu'on
voyait plein d'éléments qui n'existait
pas du tout dans les années 2000 où il
avait une petite compilation de ses
produits tout ce qui clochait hier
regarde en quatre ans
[Musique]
tu vas faire ces essais je veux pas
entendre quoi que ce soit sur la muco ou
autre ok tu vas aller faire là bas tu as
terminé
un jour je serai là en viendrait à
jeumont disent qu'ici d'accord avec ça
ça dérange et pour le coup ça je trouve
ça oui est resté amateur
n'importe quelle personne même à matrice
aurait pensé à faire sur cette heure-là
sais je trouve ça abusé cétacés se
moquer des gens à cela c'est un peu par
ici aller chercher plus loin que les
gens qui connaissent la télé y en a pas
beaucoup je pense que face à cissé sur
twitter où les téléspectateurs c'est pas
non plus 3 mais aussi des
téléspectateurs
mais si je pense que j'aurais bien vers
ce qu'a dit vraiment au moins là dessus
alors quoi raymond quand tu vois ça tu
verras quand je vois ça ça me fait
sourire ça me fait rire mais c'est vrai
que ça peut gâcher pour certains ça peut
gâcher la fête mais je m'arrête pas là
dessus moi je suis sur le fond de
l'histoire où il lui dit par exemple
extrait lui dit un jour maman je viens
de racheter mon cdma pas moi je m'arrête
sur ces histoires là qu'après il revient
il achète 10 et des médecins qui fait
pas tout la laguna du père de grégory
dormait c'était des jantes en 17 pouces
et c'est pas vrai c'était des gens temps
16 aujourd'hui mais les gens qui aiment
cette histoire est il l'homme qu'ils ont
aimés ils veulent pas qu'on se moque
d'eux ivalo qu'elle se demandait bien
biopic nous aide vraiment aidé nos
fictions à un truc inventé tu mets en
bleu tu te poses ils veulent voir des
choses vérité qu'on se moque des
gestionnaires véritable
se moque pas de télé sims a passé
plusieurs années de préparation et moi
ce que tu peux me faire de l'apnée de
chez toi c'est plus c'est plusieurs
années de préparation un film comme ça
c'est quand les scream sont payés pour
ça pour vérifier tous les états etc
c'est comme si dans un film sur
débarquement m'étais mis en musique s'il
devait ou non être à fond c'est regarder
la base débarquement dans chabada
qu'elle même occasion d'aller chercher
ses choix entre aller chercher la petite
bête d'un cd dans un rayon et une
musique de film tente tu grossis que tu
te fous tous respectent rien oui bah
tiens magath un film d'époque et tu vois
une antenne parabolique ça le dérangeait
pas est ce que ça te dérange on parle
depuis ce hall à moissac des remparts du
numéro on part d'une scène où il est
parti chercher un cd c'est cohérent
pinscher de de préhistoire avec une
antenne parabolique mais la raison mais
là vous casser la tête
c'est comme si vous comptiez les poils
de cul arrêté
[Applaudissements]
tél le philosophe joue et on termine
quand même sur un petit moment
sympathique et un moment très fort c'est
que quand grégory participé à star
académie
je vous le dis et qui fêtent
l'anniversaire d'une camarade au château
il a bien profité de la soirée
ça c'est un beau moment regarde que t'es
pas habitué
ça va durer tu sais que ta famille te
regarde là
ah ouais aux abysses moment
tu désolé c'est l'anniversaire des mini
jeux vous jettera qu'avec elle mais
qu'est-ce qui consulaire
[Applaudissements]
et le moment dont parlait répond tout à
l'heure c'est quand il découvre qu'il
est pris pour la star academy regardez
ça c'était un très très bon moment aussi
répond ça vous a ému un c'est moi je
vous le dis franchement belle bon
pourquoi parce que moi quand cantoche
d'abord j'ai lu dans les journaux le
matin quand je suis arrivé et je passais
devant l'hôpital où il est à suresnes
quand je livrais est visée il est là et
il est en train de mourir et moi j'ai
deux choses
j'aime bien quand les gens m'accompagne
dans ma vie m'a accompagné dans ma vie
il ya plein de gens qui m'accompagnent
toujours accompli ça il a dit écrit
l'histoire et n'écrit jamais la fin et
moi je fais que ça de ma vie
j'écris une erreur et j'écris jamais la
fin il mais je vais écrire moi-même les
séries il ya une anecdote que je
connaissais pas qui est très touchante
c'est que l'animatrice karine ferri a un
tatouage dédié à grégory lemarchal
voilà à regarder karine ferri oui voilà
mais elle a longtemps une intendante
yves avec son portrait autour du poids
je ne regarde qu'elle allait enlever
c'était quelque chose de faire la même
chose avec rachida et c'est vrai que je
vous le dis karine ferri a beaucoup toki
pourquoi n'était pas dans le dans le
téléfilm pourquoi l appel à l'éveil son
profil son personnage c'est franchement
son rôle apparemment été assez important
dans la vie de grégory et l'a donc les
fameux trouve ça très bon mois oui c'est
très bon c'est très beau mais là c'est
assez absent pour moi je trouve que
c'est très bien qu'elle y soit pas
l'amour aussi précaire que nikos aliagas
soit dans son propre rôle peut-être
c'est bien ça non mais je suis pas sûr
aimé ont pensé qu'il aurait pas du
regard nico est mal à trouver nico se
dit la vérité qu acteur et je pense que
justement ça nous enlève de l'émotion à
ce milieu makoun en physiquement ah oui
d'accord pas très bonne
regardez comme grégory dans la star
garde tu vas faire ces essais je veux
pas entendre quoi que ce soit sur la
muco ou autre tu vas le faire parce que
chanter te rend heureux et que c'est
peut-être la chance de ta vie qui sait
c'est que personne n'a le droit de
passer à côté de la chance de sa vie
tu ne dois jamais arrêter de te battre
craig jamais c'est comme ça tu as en
plus importé c'est comme ça tu vas
passer ces essais et tu vas aller
réussir et crois-moi peuple crois moi je
préférerais que tu restes ici pas loin
de moi comme toutes les mères sauf que
depuis que tu n'aies greg
je rêve que tu vis à vis pleinement
un bon producteur quand même que ça
super et y'en a qui ont connu voilà dans
le métier connue oui c'est pas terrible
cherche pense que c est que je ne
saurais pas avoir l'idée ils ont été les
films et aurait aimé le van gogh wajih
bravo producteurs bravo tf1 oui c'est
quand même il ya un message qui est
passé même pour les plus jeunes et je
voyais sur les tweetie hier des gens qui
dit je connaissais pas bien et des gens
qui ont fait des dons pas si lui ne
prenait pas bien sûr et quand il y tient
qu'à la mucoviscidose le je me permets
de seconde c'est toute la famille qui
l'a et c'est tous les proches et si ça
peut aider
et si ça peut aider les gens à faire
comprendre le reste je pense que c'est
que littérature
bien sûr que tu peux rajouter quelque
chose nous perdons beaucoup y avait une
chose le pierre qui est extrêmement
sympathique le père le marshall avait
dit se draper de gregor de papa de
grégory l'avez dit c'est un carré d'as
farida 604 et là ils ont un peu oublié
leslie fille la soeur qui est qui
d'ailleurs dirige l'association contre
la mucoviscidose et c'est bien dommage
qu'on n'oubliera non c'est pas vrai ce
pas alors vous avez dit long billet
karin marks karine ferri j'ai rien dit
elle était là elle était à la fin de la
vie de grégory elles étaient là au début
il dîne avec elle après il l'emmène à
chambéry on le voit et après lé là
l'hôpital n'a suivi
et là vous me dites que il a oublié sa
soeur sarah les là tout au long de du
biopic tout au long elle est là et à
quand elle est petite elle a quand est
grande et elle est là après encore dans
le reportage et l'encouragé gens arrêtés
raté voilà je bien il a une plaie
ces raisons c'est quelqu'un qui s'élève
à 4 heures du matin merci juste sait
elle elle et elle avait une vraie
relation fusionnelle avec son frère
c'est vrai que moi lac la connaissance
j'ai trouvé c'est vrai qu'elle avait
désole vraiment qu'elle est un tout
petit peu absente mais après c'est
toujours pareil je viens il ya 85 ans et
lucie aussi sur l'uci parce que tu vois
tu es là pour dire ouais j'ai pas aimé
non mais c'est un truc qui tombe dérangé
qui était petit reflétait pas la réalité
moi je les regardais hier et je trouve
que en tout cas toi tf1 pour ta pour la
part j'ai vu les autres filles des cinq
filles dans la rue à coin d'une rue en
train de faire des interviews les gars
sont dans la rue et toi tf1 et tommy
bien comme patrick fiori t'avais focus
sur toi tu as vu gilles et c'est donc
j'avais vu andré plante est tout seul on
veut des més mais et c'est le seul
chemin vers ce qu'ils ont fait quand ben
oui mais ça n'a rien à voir avec le
sujet non sujet tu sais que tu viens ici
pour dire que tes trucs tu ressemblais
pas la réalité tous les extraits qu'on a
vu sa robe pour moi un perso j'aime mais
je suis peut-être trop passion non mais
c'est comme ça
on s'en aperçoit une vitre par contre je
juste moi je suis pas venu dire que j'ai
maintenant je suis vieux je le répète
bien sûr pas
j'ai aimé mais c'est juste que voilà moi
j'ai vécu la chose et pavel tout à
l'heure je sais pas ce que vous disiez
peut-être qu'on n'avait pas envie
peut-être au fond de moi j'avais pas
envie de l'aimer au fusain mais je
l'aimé parce que ça a servi dans ces
gens c'est tout mais je le regardais
mais c'est nécessaire oui c'est à
soissons le gain pour cent c'est énorme
noir